all right so welcome to a special
Wednesday edition of the Friday bonus
show I have a guest on with me today
some of you may know him he is host of
the David Pakman show David Pakman how
are you doing today
good thank you for having me all right
so yeah I think we're gonna jump into
something that we've been talking about
all week actually the past like couple
weeks we've been discussing this we're
gonna do a chess game David's been
playing chess for about a year or two
now I've been playing for a couple weeks
and I expect to get totally smoked but I
thought that this may be interesting to
the audience so without further ado
should we start this game David yeah so
four people - we'll just explain what's
going on so we're playing on Lee chess
org and Pat made an account I have an
account there we decided in advance that
Pat would play as white-white at least
that our level arguably has a very small
advantage and it's certainly at least it
will allow Pat to use opening principles
if he has a particular opening he wants
to play and I will have to be reacting
to Pat so I think that that is the
concession I made to say we'll just
instead of leaving it to chance
Pat will play white who moves first and
we'll just describe what's going on and
we'll just get right into it it's an
untimed game and we've agreed on a
gentlemanly basis that neither one of us
is going to take an absurdly long amount
of time to think yeah I wanted a couple
handicaps at least I wanted to be able
to play as way because I'm far less
experienced I even wanted more time but
ultimately we just decided not to play a
time I wanted more than an unlimited
amount of time he wanted to infinite
amount of time yeah and David actually
studies chess he studies openings you
still have a chess coach right I haven't
taken a lesson with him for a while but
I'm still playing
yeah and now for some reason Pat your
audio drastically went down just now I
don't know if you might have hit your
mic or something yep I think we're good
here we go okay Pat moving with King's
pawn opening and I will match that as
well with my King's pawn and then Pat
bringing out his knight as well
Pat going with the four Knights four
Knights or I I'm making it a four
actually maybe I won't maybe I'll play
something a little different that scares
me I don't know what to do with that now
I'm
thinking about taking here but I don't
know if it's gonna be a good exchange
for me so I think I'm just gonna push a
pawn at this point maybe all right this
is a pretty standard opening so far
right so far pretty standard I want to
get my bishop in this equation mm-hmm
all right
my problem is I never do the
calculations of my head so I never know
at which point it's time to take right
oh jeez
all right well I'm close to castling
here so maybe I'll just do something
innocuous right that is interesting
Pat castling a very interesting
situation at this point there's a move I
don't know if I'm ready yet so eager to
attack take your time exactly that a
good move interesting I don't know if
that's gonna move oh I don't like that I
don't like that night right there yeah
we're probably right that the audio
audience wouldn't wouldn't like this no
I think it was smart video only Pat
thinking thinking thinking Oh
interesting very interesting move
all right oh man hmm is that a move oh
yeah that's it that's a that's a hell of
a move you should not be nervous at all
I have very little skill at this
sometimes I forget that the pieces have
assignments too and I'll move them
forgetting that they're doing something
right that's always bad oh geez
you're gonna get me into trouble I think
there are things you could take if you
decided you wanted to start taking
pieces I'm just happy that I have a lot
less to lose than you do I could lose
the show if I were to lose this bin it's
true oh man
I've never been so nervous in my life I
really just don't even know what to do I
feel like I've done it all as far as
you're concerned the game's over yeah
everything has a job at this point mm
mm-hmm
yeah I would definitely lose on time if
this was a time game okay I got to do
something uh let's uh let's see what
that does
mmm interesting that's an interesting
move actually in a few different ways
mm-hmm we have drawn the first blood of
the game oh wait is that a Royal Fork no
because I can kill it there you go very
good okay that was the right move
was that playing for tricks on your part
no okay David does not play for tricks
hmm
actually I'm considering a couple
different things here oh me too I have
like five or six different things I
could do right now that's a joke by the
way
okay so obviously I just want to take
with the rook but then your Bishop would
take ah I'm screwed aren't I well I
don't have to take your knight I could I
don't want to blunder my Queen either is
your queen under attack
no but if I move it it would be uh that
would be those shameful I'm just gonna
let your knight hang out there unless
you're gonna do something crazy with
that Knight
I need to know now all right I'll just
do that okay so I think that maybe a
free pawn hmm yeah you're probably right
oh man I guess dreams don't really do
come true
geez at this point I have no idea what
I'm doing
he's moving pieces so there is a
discovered check oh yeah
which is a hey those ah you got my queen
don't you unless I kill I can kill that
no I can't kill that what have I done so
the bishop is attacking that I think I
just have to give up my rook now no my
Queens in danger this is horrible
see that go through this is just
extraordinary entertaining move there
you take my queen if I move my queen in
front you take that look at the analysis
but you probably should have taken the
night when you had the opportunity
mm-hmm yeah I'm sure they'll be they'll
be chess streamers who cover this no
yeah it's gonna be groundbreaking okay
so I'm losing my rook I think no no wait
I have to move out a check so I'm losing
my queen it's over for the Queen well
the thing is if you take how you guys
know I'm participating here okay very
good so I'll take the Queen it's gone
yeah the Queen's bed and that Bishop is
now pinned oh well
Brooks the bishop isn't pinned in the
sense that you could take my bishop with
it about that I can't I kill your knight
Oh cause it would put oh no right so
then I think I put in check isn't this
what Thanksgiving is all about I'm gonna
start running away so I think now I
think how you take that rook all right
but now it is more of a question as to
what what happens do I have any of your
pieces you do have one of my Knights
that's nice yeah thank you for that
you know it's not looking good for me
when I start asking you for advice right
now yeah I'm just kind of just doing
that was a big mistake that was a big
mistake that was a big mistake okay
[Music]
I don't think it's I don't think I have
much time left do I this would be where
there might be resignations but well
never is I actually is this mating one
no matter what you do it might be
probably actually no there is there is
you could protect against that let's
move that pawn mmm see what that does
they will move yep I think that's me
so I'm gonna go back on my end let me
see if I can uh actually a game David
very good game I do want to check if the
right move was let me see if I can find
it
so here let's turn on the engine I
believe that the right move was yeah so
when I came in with the knight on move
14 and you said oh I don't have to take
the knight that's true you didn't but it
was actually the right move to take the
knight with the rook and then the the
only problem is that then I would have
been able to use my queen I would not
have taken the rook actually because if
I taken the rook then you would have
just taken the bishop and I'm actually
down to pieces for a rookie that would
have been better for you so yeah so it
actually was the right move to do that
there's definitely room for improvement
for me yeah not terribly disappointed I
did expect to lose I'm just happy I
didn't lose in like six moves yeah so
you know I'm gonna take this as a moral
victory even though it's not an actual
victory I would absolutely call it one
I'll keep studying I'll keep working at
it and who knows maybe next Thanksgiving
around that time we'll have a rematch I
would almost guarantee that if you
actually studied for a year you would be
better than me because I'm not getting
much better I basically been equally
good for about six or seven months now
so I seem to have plateaued very early
and I actually played a couple games
with my sister who's fifteen and had
never played before and it was very
clear that by the third game she was she
was already thinking in a way where if
she had proper instruction in three
months she would probably be able to
crush me but in any case she doesn't
seem interested in taking up chess well
here's the thing it seems like it's one
of those things where you you don't you
can't just play
didn't get better I mean certainly that
helps just looking at the board looking
at the puzzles that get created yeah I
mean that that helps but you also have
to study you have to like study openings
you have to study famous games you have
to maybe watch the chest streamers that
you watch and I'm honestly just I have
too many hobbies as it is I'm not going
to do any of those things
that's the question if I'm gonna be able
to improve you're not being a child
prodigy also lets you skip all that
actual stuff that you mentioned but in
any case yes is the Thanksgiving classic
the first first ever a Thanksgiving
classic thanks to everybody who joined
us apologies to everybody who hated it
but enjoy Thanksgiving and we will be
back on Monday with new show new bonus
show all of that great stuff and no more
chess for a while on the bonus show